all right guys so today we're going
to talk about um what was that uh
god what was that oh yeah short-term memory loss
now this can relate to the beginnings of dementia
all the way over to alzheimer's so the symptom
of memory loss has everything to do with the
hippocampus and the greek term for hippocampus
means seahorse because that's the shape
and you have two of them one on the left side
one on the right side so that way if one goes
you have a backup so related to short-term
memory loss i have some good news and some
bad news the bad news is that as you age the
hippocampus actually starts to shrink okay so
age is definitely one thing you're up against so
you just have to stay as young as possible number
two if you decrease oxygen you can destroy the
hippocampus number three stress will definitely
affect the hippocampus it'll actually make it
atrophy and shrink the more stress you go through
the more you can have atrophy or shrinkage
of your hippocampus i mean it's pretty easy
nowadays to avoid stress right all right number
four high glucose diabetics are at risk for having
damage to their hippocampus so high carb diets
are not very good for the hippocampus at all
number five a vitamin b1 deficiency so vitamin b1
is i would say the second most important nutrient
for the hippocampus i put some links down
below for more information about b1 because
you want to make sure you're getting enough b1
from the diet to make sure that you can preserve
the hippocampus now number six a vitamin d
deficiency out of all the areas of your brain
a vitamin d deficiency will affect the
hippocampus the most so it's a very good
thing that vitamin d deficiency is very rare
nowadays or else we'd be in big trouble now that
was a sarcasm because a vitamin d deficiency is
extremely common among most of the population on
planet earth and number seven if you have a zinc
deficiency that can majorly affect the ability
of your hippocampus to function resulting in
short-term memory loss okay so that's the bad news
what is the good news now the good news is the
hippocampus is one of the only areas of the brain
that can completely regenerate thank goodness for
that so if we just go ahead and look at the list
we have to stay as young as possible number one
we want to increase oxygen to our hippocampus
exercise is one of the best ways to do it another
way would be to use the hyperbaric oxygen therapy
but overall you want to keep your oxygen at a very
high level now the next thing would be fasting
fasting including intermittent fasting is a very
powerful therapy to increase something called
bdnf brain derived neurotrophic factor and so
by doing fasting you increase that compound
which directly increases neurogenesis which is the
creation of new nerve tissue all right next one
is to start taking vitamin d as i said before
vitamin d is the most important nutrient for
your hippocampus and also start consuming food
high in zinc that would be all the shellfish
also beef liver has a good amount of zinc
in it and taking more b1 is very very vital
i would recommend taking nutritional yeast on a
regular basis and the last thing i want to mention
is to decrease your stress as much as possible do
whatever you can to do that and of course applying
these other things is also going to reduce stress
especially if you do regular consistent exercise
the type of exercise that will increase more
oxygen long walks would be a really good thing
now the next thing is increasing your ketones
ketones are the preferred fuel of the brain
especially the hippocampus in fact you're not
going to be able to regenerate the hippocampus
without feeding it ketones and there's several
ways of increasing ketones number one getting
in a low-carb diet of course you probably
already know that if you're new to my channel
i put some links down below of exactly what diet
you need to be on number two consuming mct oil
very very important medium chain triglyceride
fats will turn into ketones and your brain will
actually absorb them in preference to glucose
and you'll see huge benefits you can also
take exogenous ketones they're called ketone
salts and that will also increase your ketones
they're a bit expensive so it might be cheaper
to take the mct oil but more important than mct
oil in exogenous ketones is getting on a ketogenic
diet keeping your carbs low and that's going to be
very very important in restoring the hippocampus
all right guys there you have it those are the
key things to help you with short-term memory
before you go if you have a question about a
product or you're new to keto and you want to
know how to begin keto or you're on keto and
you need a debug because it's not going as smooth
i have a keto consultant standing by to help you
this is just for the people in the us hopefully in
the future we'll be able to answer everyone's call
but i put the number down below
so you can call and get some help